je reçois maintenant juliette gréco
c'est juliette heureux de vous avoir
alors dites-moi gréco c'est votre vrai
nom
oui un virus et oh ouais c'est cette
lettre votre père était corse dans
soucier saphique cela alors votre père
il était travaillé au service des jeux
c'est au casino qui travaillait au
casino de nice il était commissaire
spécial il avait fait part été une très
belle guerre de 14
et c'était un homme corse très beau des
cheveux très blancs et des yeux dorés et
oui j'ai vu trois fois dans ma vie
oui hein alors votre maire c'était pas
mieux parce que votre mère vous a jamais
jamais vraiment aimé vous étiez un
enfant qu'elle qu'elle désirait passer
ça oui vous êtes retrouvés chez les
soeurs à l'âge de 12 ans et là il ya un
épisode assez étonnant je vous êtes dans
le dans le sud-ouest de la france votre
mère fait de la résistance 1 grande
résistante on peut le dire elle est
arrêtée et vous montez avec votre soeur
charlotte à paris pour dans l'espoir de
la libérer c'est ça s'était très quand
même ça me choque quand même savoir nous
sommes d'abord allés périgueux
et ça va pas marcher et
ensuite nous avons pris le train pour
paris en essayant de chercher ce qui
allait se passer et pourquoi ce qu'on
n'était pas très bien compris on n'était
pas très grande enfin moi j'étais plutôt
petit que je n'ai qu'un examen pas 14
niveaux votre soeur ce fait se fait
arrêter qu'elle laisse tomber son sac
vous récupérez le ca que vous les laisse
pas tomber dans sa cale elle a posé dans
la voiture et moi je savais que dans mon
sac avait des papiers donc j'ai insisté
pour rentrer dans la voiture et et en
sortant j'ai pris son sac et j'ai laissé
le mien vous avez tout déchiré tous les
papiers qui étaient compromettants
l'intérieur s'est retrouvé à fresnes en
prison et donc vous arrivez à
saint-germé vous habitez dans une
pension de famille chez une amie de
votre mère rue servan des laïcs
voilà c'est une norme comédienne est là
le personnage de greco nez c'est à dire
les manches retroussées des parce que
vous aviez pas d'argent pour vous
acheter des valses l'air sont m'habiller
ouais et donc vous retrousser les
manches peuple c'est comme ça que j'ai
laisseront ils étaient les ballons
je connais mes pantalons bas elle
parlait pas parce qu'après ce que vous
aviez subi et vous n'aviez pas envie de
laisser parler c'est ça ça ça faisait
partie du personnage distante mois après
j'ai connu plein de filles qui limitait
gillet brico était petit gréco milliards
oui c'est ça oui il ya eu plein alors à
la fin de la guerre vous retrouvez votre
mère l'hôtel lutetia qui revient d'un
camp de concentration
c'est terrible c'est à dire qu'elle vous
ils vous demandent des nouvelles de
quelqu'un avant de vous avant de vous
embrasser
oui dur alors là vous devenez la muse
l'égérie l'icône de saint germain des
prés alors maquillée comme une
égyptienne avec les traits noirs
scandaleuse parce qu'on se rend pas
compte maintenant sur moi quand j'étais
petit on parlait de greco c'était un peu
sulfureux quand même c'était pas
maintenant complète pas c'était voilà on
m'a jeté des pierres sur les champs
elysées oui c'est ça le 8 août a fait
chez nous accuser de lahoud est
responsable de la dépravation d'adé la
jeunesse enfin c'était une image qui
était pas ce qu'on appellera près avec
le rock ou avec le pain coup ou même
maintenant avec le gangsta rap quoi
c'était vraiment c'était beaucoup plus
fort encore parce que c'était tout à
coup l'image d'une fille libre et la
liberté
chaque jour les gens c'est une des
choses les plus les plusieurs langues et
libère alors j'ai lu votre notice
biographique dans le who's who alors ça
je crois y a que vous qui doit voir ça
parce que c'est formidable c'est dans le
who's who ya marqué le prêt lui à metz
extraordinaire ya marqué c'est rare il
ya marqué que vous animiez le cabaret le
tabou avec anne-marie cazalis votre
copine les grandes amies un harry
cazalis raymond queneau roger vadim
boris vian et jean paul sartre avoir ça
dans le dans le who's who je pense que
personne c'est inespéré quoi je sais
plus brillant que cette information
ouais moi vous si vous étiez client lui
il exactement soit vous l'annoncions
payés oui alors là vous rencontrez
merleau ponty qu'un grand un grand
penseur grand philosophe qui vous
explique l'existentialisme sur des coins
de table et un jour ils vous présentent
sartre au bal [ __ ] c'est anne marie
anne marie qui vous la présenter le mari
cazalis et là ça aussi c'est un truc que
je savais pas jean paul sartre devient
producteur de disques une certaine façon
apple il ya assez sarde producteur il
vous donne des dépôts m oui il a créé
les chansons pour moi qui m'en ont été
volés et que je n'ai jamais pu récupérer
et il m'a donné aussi la chanson qu'il
avait écrite pour un huis clos qui était
la rue des blancs manteaux mais dont il
a fait refaire la musique l'avait fait
une musique l'aide chez lui ce sens et
pas du tout y est
et il n'était pas satisfait de sa
musique il a donc donné à à kosma oui
car fait musique est donc là il vous
donne un livre dans le livre y avait des
signes est comme ça vous regarde et vous
tombez sur si tu t'imagines de huy de
queneau alors là il continue d'ailleurs
il vous dit qui vous pensé pour la
musique soit vous discuté ensemble ou
choisissez cosma parce qu'il venait de
faire les les feuilles mortes et trois
jours après vous commencez au fameux
boeuf sur le toit
voilà c'était là où tous les gens que je
que j'admirais avaient passé leur temps
pendant les années 30 0 c'était aux
champs elysées de l'autre côté de
maintenant il y en a un sur le toit rue
du colisée c'est celle là c'est lui
c'est elle à lui via la 4e dilate et là
où jouer
des gens comme
comme génère doucet à deux pianos c'est
là aussi calé cocteau tous les soirs
c'est là aussi qu'à chanter marianne
oswald magnifique marian hossa l'a alors
après boutique
après il ya la carrière qu'on qu'on
connaît il ya la rose rouge le vieux
colombier puis toutes les chansons que
vous avez chanté effectivement vous êtes
une interprète des quelques personnages
quand on lit votre vie à quelques
personnages que ça qu'ils ont marqué
c'est boris vian si vous prenez sur son
épaule comme ça et j'avais de très
grands cheveux me prenait il entourait
mais j'ai paul avec son grand bras et
puis charisme est chaud comme ça et puis
me parlait il a fini par obliger à
parler sans que je me rende compte
j'ai recommencé à avoir un échange avec
quelqu'un ait cet échange se passait
toujours le soir dans le noir ils me
paient les lumières ça et on parlait
j'écoutais paris point c'est comme on
dit vulgairement oui je sais le plus c
est plus merveilleux j'analyse que j'ai
que j'ai pu avoir
et un jour alors pareil vous voyez
arriver un jeune mec qui fait tomber son
whisky tellement à la première rencontre
c'est gainsbourg évidemment qui à
l'époque avait sept têtes absolument
ovniesque magnifique mais moi je le
trouvais beau moi et vous vous adonnez
la javanaise qu'effectivement il a
écrite pour vous un matin alors quand
vous étiez à fresnes en prison vous ai
fréquenté des prostituées
je vais tenter non résidentes et les
filles qui étaient là oui beaucoup de
prostituées dans ta bouche moi c'était
le choix de la gestapo absolument je me
suis retrouvé avec 3,3 pour situer très
bien j'ai appris j'étais à l'école du
trottoir
c'était pas tant vous avez appris un
truc c'est que les hommes faut surtout
les laisser parler de quoi ça c'est une
grande leçon ça qu'on peut dire qu'ils
aiment par le gie apprécié à toutes
celles imposées après ça tout de même
une mouche bon et vous aimiez séduire
parce que peut-être parce que votre mère
vous avez pas assez aimée vous aviez
envie de séduire je vais pas faire la
psychanalyse de bistrot non non je crois
à toute femme a envie de chez tout être
humain en vue de séduire et latents et
séduire vous à moi j'ai envie de vous
séduire
silence oui mais si c'est laisser la vie
de séduire l'autre et est de réussir à
avoir un échange
alors là vous fait refaire le nez alors
ça ça a été un événement pour plus
séduire donc fait refaire le nez non non
ce comptoir d'amour c'est parce que le
monsieur que j'ai mais à cette époque là
un jour à poser son doigt sur mon il a
dit qu'il est long ce bonnet aïe aïe aïe
1 et chalets il est maréchal et chez le
docteur
à l'époque c'était courant pas courant
c'était à tous les courants du tout mais
ça se faisait déjà quand même je pense
que oui oui c'est vraiment aimé ça
commencer quoi ça commence et ouais ça a
commencé c'était un médecin explique
klaus qui faisaient ça en général
ouais donc à bas après alors voilà après
il ya toutes vos aventures donc vous
rencontrez darif d'années qui veut se
faire faire du cinéma hollywood et donc
qui vous fait tourner des films
d'ailleurs pas seulement qu'il veut qui
vous fait tourner les films vous
plaisait pas tellement vous faites les
racines du ciel fait tout ainsi si ça me
ça me plaisait pas ce que c'était un
instant privilégié de rencontre et que
j'ai rencontrés là des gens absolument
extraordinaire oui vous étiez en fait
vous l'avez rencontré bill chantier
waldorf astoria britannique mais le
ferrer et audrey hepburn et janick avait
une petite critique dans le times où il
y avait une
une petite photo et je chante au waldorf
astoria et il a dit à amel essayé de
l'appeler et eddie lui qu'elles viennent
parce que je voudrais qu'elle tourne ce
rôle dans les rues d'accord dans les
veaux si il voulait vraiment faire de
vous une grande star d'hollywood a
attrapé tout d'un coup vous avez des
roses rouges de baccarat tous les matins
parce qu'ils savaient vivre et je
n'avais pas chez dommage
ouais osé connu miles davis aussi
qu'elle était enfin je sais pas si
c'était un nouveau grand amour mais vous
vous avez été sûrement son grand amour
mais profondément belge voyait brando
qui vous rend menée en moto jst crise
n'est plus tôt pour herta kit que pour
vous à piacere s'agit résulté fois vous
regarde sa quête j'étais un homme exquis
il était de niveau tu est troublante
vous dis tu toujours partie la première
parce que pourquoi parce que vous
trouvez que les hommes sont pas à la
hauteur un moment et vous l'asse ça non
quand je m'ennuie quoi ouais alors j'ai
pas le temps de m'ennuyer
vous avez été mariée dont vous avez
trois maris vous dis d'air mais trois
maris m'ont demandé en mariage ça leur
faisait plaisir moi je m'en foutais
complètement du philippe lemaire tête un
acteur qu'on a oublié quand quelqu'un
qui était assez jolie qui avait un
visage un peu vieux jeu quand même même
est assez joli
dix-huit mois avec lui une fille vous
dites qu'ils comptent pas michel piccoli
mariage surprise en 68 j'aime beaucoup
beaucoup michel niveau métier vous ont
séparé 10 on jouera les d'admiration
vous beaucoup d'admiration de respect de
tendresse pour michel mais je préfère
attention amis que ses fans et votre
dernier mari celui heures le en cours
alise là bien lui va bien et vous
adonner en 88 il ya dix ans vous aviez
un peu envie de tout laisser tomber vous
a donné la pêche pour lui c'est un homme
magnifique c'est un magnifique
compositeur et c'est rien un personnage
humain un être humain
dernière question est ce que
vous avez été vous avez une aventure
avec le coureur automobile vimy a été un
grand héros et vous dites quand il est
mort
après c'est plus comme avant c'était
vraiment votre grand amour wimille
c'était le premier oui le premier grand
amour amérique c'était mon meilleur
amour et je l'aimé passionnément
passionnément
c'est pour lui que vous êtes fait
refaire le nez j'en étais sûr bon ben
merci voyage était heureux de vous
connaître et je pense que tout le monde
a été intéressée de survoler cette
grande carrière merci beaucoup cette
grande vie aussi et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de finale andy tu es abonné
vous mettez un pouce bleus